[Music]
use it okay and now I start looking for
this arm you see I don't let him grab
onto it or anything start to follow it
follow that energy okay and once you get
here don't go for that
turn take his Center out first ever so
slightly boom and now go for the turn
push down do you see well that's where
you
have all those things that we were
working on okay so here I have goo
here's my elbow and he postures up
you're going to have a hard time getting
it but that's what opens up the hip bump
okay so they play off each other if I'm
trying for the hip bump and he starts to
posture down then you ATT the arm cuz
he's coming back forward entering into
the y space he if he resists on me like
he's pushing back okay don't I won't
keep going I go ahead and attack the arm
and go where he's going okay I moved
myself out so if you can't get his if if
he's really resisting there and he can't
I can't get his shoulder down right then
I'll Attack the
wrist here we're I'll Attack the elbow
here okay if I get them all the way down
then I go to the shoulder
lock and we come around and he's really
strong he overpowers his right hand it's
straightening his arm I go around the
arm and trap it on my neck I take the
arm he fights it I go around the arm and
he falls into the elbow lock